when i was 16
i got really sick
i was run down working hard in school
not eating properly
and i got pneumonia
and an abscess
developed on my lung
well
one day the abscess burst
and i emerged
i needed blood
pretty sure everybody thought i might
die
obviously i didn't
but some say that
god saved me
believers think god communicates to us
through miracles
that miracles are proof of the divine
now i'm going on a journey to discover
the power of miracles
you fell from up there down to here what
did the doctor say
you are a miracle
to discover what's locked
and what is fate
in the chinese thought everything has a
reason for why it occurred to see how
belief in miracles
can change history the miracles
symbolize the beginning of the jewish
people
and how faith can change lives
you are looking at a true miracle of god
to achieve
what appears to be
impossible
the real miracle is to transform the
human mind that's the miracle we need
[Music]
most who believe in god
believe god is watching over us
every moment
of every day
guiding us
saving us
to me
it has to be a miracle that he can look
out for all seven billion of us
so when i heard about alcides moreno
i had to come to new york and hear his
story
well here we are
eight years ago alcitis came to work as
a window washer at this 47-story tower
in manhattan
tell me about it what happened when i
wake up
in the morning take my car and commute
from new jersey and
come to the building
you take the elevator and go all the way
to the top the top is forty seven eighty
four stairs yes
and climb to the platform
alcidus had just begun to lower the
platform
when one of the two cables holding it
snapped
i just grabbed the scaffold
and has hole up until another cable is
not
[Applause]
the paramedics they found them right in
the mirror
the scaffold like that between the two
buildings yeah we turned to it right it
was try in the middle they picked me up
from there
alcitus fell 47 stories
500 feet he broke 10 bones
his lungs collapsed
he needed 43 pints of blood and plasma
he spent three weeks in a coma
do you remember
the day you woke up
from the coma i wake up december 24th
right there on the bed
and
my wife was there
a fall from just 10 stories is something
hardly anyone survives
doctors say alcitis's 47 story plunge
was beyond belief
i've seen it all or at least i think i
have until uh something like this
happens
you fell from up there down to here
yes
[Music]
and here
here you are
yes sir
and look at him
walking
everything give me a name for that i
mean the doctor told me you are a
miracle man say
you are a miracle what do you think
i don't know
still i don't know
alcides has a hard time accepting this
as a miracle
because he was not alone when he fell
his younger brother was on this platform
with him
he died the moment he hit the ground
what was your brother's name
erica
edgar
there we are
yeah so faces thank you very nice
my brothers are big loss to me
were you close really really close
that was a great man
i'm sorry i'll see this
it must be very painful yes
i just bring it to work with me
to help it out because
he's younger oh yes that was younger
than me
that was a good man
[Music]
think god saved you
die diesel yeah i believe that
yes
so that makes you the miracle
but at the same time
your brother is gone the one you do you
worry about that do you do you try to
reconcile that
try to figure out why
him
hey not me not you why yes i asked him
why why what happened
why
it was me
i would wonder every day
god gave me a second chance i mean
through
to keep going though
to keep going on my
life and
i still
looking forward to find out what exactly
i have to do
now see this is no longer a window
washer
he and his wife have a new life in
arizona
where they are raising their family
he's still trying to understand whether
god has a plan for him
why me
does god have a purpose for me
arcedus
wonders
why did i survive
when
my beloved brother
did not why i mean
is there some entity that makes that
choice
or
is uh
do we live with
randomness just
pure mindless randomness
for christians
miracles are proof that life is not
random
they believe god intervenes in the world
for a reason jews also believe in the
power of miracles
in fact
their faith was built on a bedrock of
divine intervention
i've come to jerusalem
to see how jews celebrate the miracles
of their exodus from egypt
on a night that's different from all
other nights
passover
hi hello there how do you do i'm very
well added this is for you thank you
very much and i'm a fifa welcome to my
home you do oh lord
[Music]
grab
[Music]
is the first israeli-born woman ever to
become a rabbi
yeah i've known a few rabbis
never a lady
i hope you enjoyed the seder
and we'll do our utmost to make it uh
food i'll be okay food food
this is the um
and you get to taste it and we're going
to decide if it you got to make it feel
it's got to make you feel as if you're
getting drunk
is it whiny enough
he'll tell you the truth
i think it's enough i think it's enough
too
okay guys let's get started say though
starting
come on
everybody sit down
one of the most important traditions in
judaism and this has been ordered to us
from our ancestors thou shall not speak
on your cell phone during the seder
so we have a cell phone basket here
the monster we came out of egypt is
called in hebrew nissan
and his nissan comes from the word nisim
which is miracles it's the month of the
miracles
which
will symbolize the beginning of the
jewish people as the people
as an entity
the way we go with the seder is that we
we read through the haggadah so morgan
as our guest we would welcome you to
start with the bread of affliction
this is the bread of affliction that our
fathers ate in the land of egypt that
all that are hungry enter and to eat
and all who are in want come and
celebrate the passover
this year we are slaves
next year
we shall be free men
[Music]
the passover meal is a celebration of
the bond jews feel with god
and it's an occasion for children to
understand the foundation of their faith
[Music]
the seder recounts how the jews escaped
slavery
thanks to god striking the egyptians for
the series of ten plagues
so rabbi yeah why passover what is the
word itself referred to
when god brought upon egypt the tense
plague of killing the firstborn he told
the israelites to put blood on the
thresholds of their homes
and the angel of death
passed over the homes of the hebrews and
only took
the firstborn of the egyptians
many jews believed god's sparing of
their children was proof they were his
chosen people
but this was not the only divine sign
the miracle of getting out of egypt was
followed by the miracle of splitting of
the sea
god made two miracles one was splitting
the sea before the hebrews and then
closing it before the egyptians
so god wants us to remember the
egyptians are just
his sons as we are
so by
putting drops of
wine on our plates we're actually
putting drops of sorrow that god had
lost
so many of his
children while saving the others
this acknowledgment that the exodus
miracles didn't benefit everyone
reminds me of alcitus moreno
divine will is not easy to understand
so what is your take
on
the whole idea of the series of miracles
i don't think anybody's going to split
the sea for us today
i wish somebody would bring peace to us
today but
the bible is not a
book of history the bible is a book of
ideas the question is what can we learn
from it what can we take into our own
life
it's the way of saying thank you you
know it's a way of teaching the kids
that every small thing is not granted
that you need to say
thank you
it's nice to have parents
it's lovely to have a roof above your
head
that's probably the biggest miracle
of all of them at that
jews are still here
i want them to come out with the idea
that miracles can happen
that's the story
the israelites saw these
miracles
as proof that god cared about them
not all modern jews believe in the
miracles of passover but these stories
still define them as a people
and that deep well of
tradition and moral strength
has sustained them
been called on by them for thousands of
years
to get them through hard times
around the world belief in miracles
gives people strength
in mexico city the basilica of our lady
of guadalupe
marks the spot where the virgin mary is
said to have appeared to a peasant
500 years ago
in hong kong
buddhist pilgrims flock to the statue of
guanyin who they hope will grant them
medical cures a spouse or good grades
and in rome miracles can turn ordinary
people into saints
i've come to the vatican to understand
how the catholic church verifies
miracles
i think the first time i was at the
vatican was about 1983.
i'm meeting monsigno marcelo sanchez
sorondo
the head of the pontifical academy of
sciences
so let's talk just for a moment about
miracles
the americans really exist
for instance jesus walking on water
in the life of christ if you
don't accept it the miracles it's
impossible to understand
each page of the gospel is a miracle of
christ to consider person is hunt
the church need a miracle in order to
have saints you have to have miracles
yes
unless you are a martyr the only way to
sainthood is to be deemed responsible
for performing two miracles after you
die
pope john paul ii became a saint in 2014
after two women who prayed to him after
his death claimed to be miraculously
cured
one of parkinson's disease
another of a brain aneurysm
the vatican spends years investigating
these claims sometimes decades
the church has a devil's advocate who
goes and whenever anybody
claims to have
seen or experienced a miracle the church
sends the advocate to
investigate yes they have to advocate
and have scientific people special
doctors
to to prove that this this is a special
intervention of god so if i
come
and say i have experienced america with
the church then say okay well we'll
check that out exactly
[Laughter]
we're going to check
does the hand of god really intervene
not just in matters of life and death
but also in the ups and downs of our
daily lives
or does everything that happens
happen by chance
[Music]
what
if anything
governs the seemingly random moments
that change our lives and send us into
different directions
like
a poor boy from mississippi ending up in
hollywood
i always loved the movies
always dreamed i would be in them
i was a believer
and
i actually made it
now was that a miracle
[Music]
most of us have a turning point in our
lives
a pivotal moment where you wondered how
did this happen
mine was 1989.
i made three films
lean on me
driving miss daisy
and glory
did i make it happen
was someone up there calling the shots
or was i
lucky
to try to understand this i've arranged
to meet a psychology professor
who thinks we often mistake random
chance for miracles
danny oppenheimer it's nice to see you
how are you today i'm good you i'm good
good
what are you doing
i'm flipping coins
why i'm looking for streaks streaks yeah
if you flip a coin enough times you're
gonna get a streak really
that's a lot of tails well if i flip a
coin twice and i get heads both time is
that miraculous
uh no you do it 50 times and you get 60.
that's a miracle well yeah if you get
more than you flip certainly but how
rare does an event have to be before we
would call it miraculous one in a
million one in a billion i'll choose
billion all right one in a billion
but let's try something
all right
jack of diamonds six of spades
king of spades two of hearts seven of
diamonds and ace of spades
is it miraculous to have gotten this
sequence
no
i mean it's just just a random selection
of cards off the deck well right but
this particular sequence starting with
the jack and then getting the six of
spades and then king of spades it only
happens one in about 14 billion times
you draw six cards so it's pretty
miraculous by your one and a billion
standard
so you're telling me that
this is miraculous well no as you said
before it's just a random set of cards
what if it was first six digits of your
social security number what if it were
the last six digits of your social
security number the first six digits of
your phone number sometimes it's not
actually miraculous sometimes it's just
probability playing its uh tricks on you
all right so how do we include the
divine because there are people who
really do think that there is divine
intervention in these kinds of
interplays absolutely and nothing i'm
saying here rules out the possibility of
the divine the fact that probability
predicts certain things doesn't mean
that there can't be divine intervention
but miraculous things that are so
unlikely that you think it can't happen
by chance alone they do happen and they
have to happen it would be odd if they
didn't because with six billion people
in the world there are so many
opportunities for something really
unusual to happen we would expect it to
happen to some of them
it's human nature to make a symphony out
of the cacophony of events going on
around us
doesn't mean that divine providence
doesn't exist
in fact
as i learned when i was in rome
in the past
chance and god coexisted
the ancient romans had a different take
on miracles
before they became christians
romans had many gods
they believed the gods controlled their
fate
and everything that happened was decided
by them
archaeologist valerie higgins tells me
the gods even determined the outcome of
sporting events
so we're here in the circus maximus this
was the largest uh circus in rome in
fact in the roman empire
and this was where they did chariot
racing we are actually standing
on the track
yeah the starting gates were down there
and they would race through here up to
the other end where they would turn
around and then go back down that end
and they would do that seven times
at least a quarter of a million people
could fit in here
yeah right so this was a place that was
full of life and full of action well it
must have been uh quite a lot like uh
modern day horse racing you know bedding
and
wagering and sure yes we know there was
lots of betting and lots of gambling
gambling particularly on dice games was
frowned upon because
you were betting on the will of the gods
but widespread gambling began to change
the way romans thought about fate
and open the way for belief in miracles
how did gambling fit with the idea that
your fate was already set no matter what
you did
you were going to wind up the way you
were going to wind up
they did very much believe that their
fate was uh set but
you know it didn't make them passive
they certainly did everything they could
to get the gods behind their riders well
i would ask like for instance of a day
of the big race you know
uh and the ancient romans were thinking
well it's in the hands of the gods but
we need to know what the gods want right
right
how would we figure that out how did
they go about figuring out what the
guards wanted what the gods wanted well
you had to go to a priest who was
specialized in this sort of thing
just around the corner from the
racetrack
hidden in an alleyway and down in a
basement
valerie takes me to see the remains of
the temple that dates back to the third
century
a place where romans may have tried to
twist
the will of the gods
this is spectacular yes it is what we're
coming into now is a mithraeum mythreon
yeah that's right it's
a special kind of ritual space
for
the cult of
mithras he's the god he's killing the
bull
mithras was a god for men
tough men soldiers
powerful businessmen
so we're here in this mithraium which is
kind of like the original man cave we
know they did a lot of feasting would
there be any of the uh uh uh priests
down here there would be priests down
here yes i think for sure um who would
be overseeing the feasting because it
was quite essential that you did the
ritual you know correctly to ensure that
your team was going to be successful in
the circus maximus so
here we are down here and we're doing
all of the rituals and so are we really
trusting
the
fates to take care of what we want taken
care of or do we do a little no that
doesn't stop you giving fate a helping
hand
certainly we know there was a lot of
cheating that went on uh in the circus
maximum oh i'm afraid sir they did
everything they could to make things
work to make them successful and they
certainly weren't above cheating the
fact that you were allowing the gods to
decide uh your fate didn't mean that you
couldn't help them along
if you could uh yeah yeah you know
because their idea is that the god works
for you and that's in every aspect of
your life including of course your team
racing in the circus maximus
romans don't have faith they just follow
the rituals
they had fates quite right they had
faith not faith
that h makes a big difference
the ancient romans believed that if you
were good to the gods
they would be good to you
every single event from winning a
chariot race to rolling of the dice
could be the result of divine
intervention
a minor miracle
i'm just trying to work out
how a couple of millennia of catholicism
might have changed the way the romans
think
do they still think god will intercede
and reward their faith with
a royal flush perhaps
the idea that nothing in our lives
happens by chance did not die with the
culture of ancient rome it remains alive
and well in the chinese philosophy and
religion taoism
taoism dates back nearly two millennia
gods are not the focus of taoism the
focus is the tao the ultimate creative
energy of the universe to which we are
all connected this
interconnectedness means our fates are
all set at birth
so
do daoists believe miracles are possible
to find out i'm heading to the heart of
the chinese community in los angeles
to meet a fourth generation taoist fate
calculator named ginny liu
jimmy lou morgan freeman yes ma'am nice
to meet you thank you for my name please
thank you
so
did you do my life chart i did we have
your hair as june 1st so 6 1 19 37 2 am
is that correct
your life map lets us know where over
120 stars are located at your time of
birth
these stars configure a certain energy
field that impact the quality and
success of your life
so in chinese we don't call this
astrology actually we call it
fate calculation
fate calculation covers your life in 10
year periods you can see from age 6 to
15 is 1 60 and 25
and so on so forth so what's now between
seven to six and eighty-five right now
you're in your friendship sector in your
friendship sector the star that's there
is called one time this star represents
scholars learned it people these are the
people that you wanna surround
yourselves with so far so good so far so
good and one of the reasons why maybe
you have not come here yet until today
is one of the stars in your personal
sector is called lienzen and linzen is
the adventurer
somebody who likes to take things as
they come
so if my fate is already laid out
does that leave room for like
miracles absolutely we don't think of
astrology chart as predestined that it's
your only fate that's carved in stone
we see a life map just like we say life
is a journey
and go on any journey you need to have a
map there's going to be dead ends
there's going to be multiple potholes if
you know where they are
you're still in charge of your own car
this is just a navigation system you can
learn if you understand how you're
connected to everything around you that
is the miracle waiting to happen
so is this connected to feng shui
feng shui this is based on the taoist
thought
everything around us is connected
everything is made of energy we're all
connected through this energy boom
is
wind
sway is water
it's an energy that we cannot destroy or
create it's always there but we can
divert it we can harness it
in china
we can ride it exactly i was going to
say in chinese so say
birds do not fly they are flown
fish do not swim they are carrot they
are carried they are swum
by water
they always think particularly in
christianity that a miracle is a result
of divine intervention
in the chinese thought everything is
connected
everything has a reason for why it
occurred
thank you thank you
fong sue wind
water
birds don't fly
they ride the wind
fish don't swim
they're carried
everything that happens to us is result
of all the things
that we are connected to
what we call divine intervention
is merely connections we weren't aware
of
makes me wonder if we
shouldn't
maybe stop trying so hard to control our
lives
and learn to ride the wave of life
our lives are filled with unexpected
twists and turns
some believe there's nothing beyond
randomness
others say we're propelled by the will
of god
or the energy of the universe both those
beliefs could make the difference
between life and death because the human
mind could have a hidden power to
unleash a miracle
i'm traveling the world trying to
understand the power of miracles
and i've come to cairo to find out if
that power could come from our own minds
i'm visiting one of the world's oldest
hospitals
a place that was famous for combining
medical science with the healing power
of belief
so the writings around the building
describe the founding of this hospital
and of the entire complex
harvard historian of islam and physician
ahmed bhagat has brought me to the
koller woon complex
first opened its doors around 1285 a.d
this would be the entrance through which
patients would normally walk
wow
this is a dramatic change from outside
this is actually by design
when you walk into this corridor from
the outside the sunny and the dirty
streets and it's very noisy you walk in
here it's a dark calm shaded corridor
[Music]
patients came here hoping to be cured by
both cutting edge medicine
and a miraculous intervention from god
i want to show you something here oh
okay
oh my
goodness
the construction here is the most
impressive thing ever that i think i've
seen anywhere
this is the shrine of sultan khalawun
the founder of this hospital
patients who have come in and offered a
prayer of thanks for the sultan
slowly khaloon himself becomes connected
to the idea of healing it's like in this
history we're looking at the making of a
healing saying
does that mean that there becomes a
connection between
faith and
healing medicine as a whole was seen as
the conduit of the will of god so at the
end of the day we fall sick um in part
this is something that god dwells and we
would only be healed through medicine
but only by the will of god exactly
actually everything that happens is the
will of god exactly
[Music]
centuries ago
muslims believed faith and medicine
worked hand in hand
but can belief in divine intervention
actually help medicine heal us today
tom renfrow is familiar with the cliche
the miracle of modern medicine
because he's a practicing physician
but he also believes in divine miracles
and that one happened to him
[Music]
it was 18 years ago
that i stood there to give thanks
to god for healing me
and what i told you at that time
was you are looking at a true miracle
a miracle of god
the hunt for miracle stories has brought
indiana university scholar candy gunter
brown
to norton virginia
to meet tom
she's studying whether faith and prayer
can actually improve medical outcomes
the question that i really interests me
is what happens when people pray for
healing candy it was in 1996 in the fall
of that year
that i found a nodule on the back of my
neck
later on that fall i found more nodules
under my arm
and i sought medical attention
and the biopsy under my arm showed that
i had an unusual
form of lymphoma called mantle cell
lymphoma
the prognosis was very poor and they
gave me months to live and basically
told me enjoy what time you have left
and the goal is to hopefully keep me
alive
through christmas
i was a physician
i knew the objective evidence that was
there i was in multi-organ failure
i had a disease that there was no
medicine or cure for that would wipe
this disease out
instead of despair the lord wants us to
remember
i have brought you all this way i'm not
going to leave you here by yourself did
you have medical treatments
uh no i did not have medical treatments
not at that time the tumors continued to
progress
and as they progressed the people came
together
more and more intense with prayer
our pastor organized
a week in prayer
to where people would come and pray
perhaps even all night and it was a
remarkable time
by now the tumors were the size of
apples on my neck my arms stuck out
because of the massive adenopathy under
my arms my abdomen was expanding
i was dying
the lord actually spoke to me and said
now is the time to go to the hospital
chemotherapy typically only delays the
progress of metal cell lymphoma
it's not a cure
so
they started an infusion
and it was like the rock that that david
threw at goliath
before the infusion even completed
there was something that changed in me
physically
the tumors they became like a nerf ball
like a sponge
and very soft
and they started disappearing
in front of your eyes
and all this massive adenopathy
just disappeared
over the next
24-48 hours
it was gone
do you ever wonder did the chemotherapy
just work better than
the doctors expected it to work the
chemotherapy it wasn't designed to cure
no one expected
the tumors to utterly start disappearing
or melting i should have died multiple
times during this illness
from pulmonary embolisms from pneumonia
from renal failure
but i had faith
i had people that poured
their words into me to encourage me
and i believe through that that god
intervened
and healed me
and here we are
18 years later
me talking to you
to me that is a miracle
that is a miracle that i'm here
why did tom renpro survive
when so many people who pray for healing
don't make it
tom believes the power of his faith
and that of the people around him
helped the chemotherapy achieve the
impossible
it strikes me
that much of what we call miraculous
starts right here
in the mind
we close our eyes in prayer don't we
and i think that's because the goal is
to focus the mind
to transcend the distractions of
everyday life
to set our minds to achieve
what
at first we might fear
is impossible
i've come to india to explore a religion
that believes we all have the mental
power to perform miracles
this is the mahabodhi temple in bodhgaya
according to buddhist tradition 2 500
years ago a man named siddhartha gautama
came to the realization that the human
mind had immense untapped powers
in doing so
he founded an entirely new religion
buddhism
and tradition says he did it
right here
under this tree
i want to understand what buddhists
believe happened to siddhartha as he sat
under the tree
tibetan monk los angeles has promised to
help me find out
so
that's winter i'm glad you could come oh
me too
so this is our holiest spot
where the buddha attained awakening
losing tells me he'll get me to
understand the miracle of the buddha's
enlightenment and he'll do it by
challenging my mind
to get me to see the light myself
so what do you know about
what do you know about
what do they teach you in america i
learned that he was of noble birth
and uh he grew up very very sheltered
and said that and then one day he
wandered out of the compound that's
right
and began to see
right because it really was yep why why
why did he do that
that's the question you're going to
answer well how would you like it if
your father had decided as soon as you
were born that this baby of mine is
going to be the king
so i've got to keep him in this palace
surrounded by beautiful sense objects
flowers that never drew beautiful young
ladies who never look old perfect isn't
that perfect
but this guy wasn't satisfied with that
would have left the palace right yes and
you know what he saw when he left the
palace
well
as i understand it he saw suffering
he saw real
life at home
well there were
old people
cripples
and beggars
people who had nothing people were
hungry yeah it's like a it's like an eye
opener it's like a wow he's so dead yeah
his father his father didn't want him to
see death it made him think so strongly
he felt i've got to leave this place and
find out what is the cause of this why
do people
suffer siddhartha roamed for six years
seeking to understand the cause of
suffering
until he finally came to the shade of a
ficus tree
and decided that he would stay right on
that spot focusing his mind
until he discovered how to end human
suffering
after sitting motionless for an entire
night
siddhartha achieved a mental
transformation
buddhists say
he became the buddha the enlightened one
[Music]
taught us
he said you know what a good doctor
would tell a patient man you're sick
you're sick you're suffering you know
you have a problem second i know the
cause
basically this craving attachment
the buddha realized that by letting go
of his desires and his attachment to the
material world he could rid himself of
suffering
for the buddha and for generations of
buddhists after him this freedom from
attachment seems to allow a remarkable
perhaps even miraculous mental and
physical focus
you know he was so grateful to this tree
under which he sat and achieved this
amazing realization he sat in this area
for seven weeks and for one of those
weeks just gazing unwinkingly they say
unmoving
and unblinking
for seven days
it's possible why not we haven't
exercised our minds we're so busy with
external things buying and selling and
doing all the things we can do never
actually seen a yogi in in action well
in a sense it's an amazing thing but you
and i can do it
buddhist years of mental training
and showing love and compassion to
others
can free them from suffering
walking around this temple
you feel like a miracle really could
happen
the miracle of people being content with
their lives
[Music]
people getting along together
do you want to just come and see how
tibetan llama teaches western students
how are you i am well how are you sir
i'm very good i assure you i'm moving oh
you did which one
i don't know
who else likes my movie
shortcut we all
need to care and love and respect each
other
that is the source of happiness
whoever had that
their journey is good
whoever not keep this in a heart journey
is not
thank you
from today you are my friend
where
[Music]
okay i like you
so
a lot of religions
are
pretty much
miracle-based i mean christianity
judaism right really right uh
you don't do miracles but what's a
miracle i mean
lying in the sky is that a miracle it
but we
normally think of miracles as some sort
of divine
thing something that okay that gives us
proof of god or something you know
okay so that we could ask where is god
we ask the mystics or the yogis
where's god
they'll point here they won't point up
there they'll say it's in here
so then if you're being inspired by your
inner god
buddha christ you know krishna whatever
you want to call it
maybe then you can
perform what's called a miracle
what does this world need the most
it needs healing right love
it needs uh
reconciliation
i think that's a miracle and that's the
miracle we need we don't need
people levitating three inches off their
butt you know while meditating that's
stupid so let's stick to the real
miracle which is to transform the human
mind really all right
you know what you just did what you
solved the problem with miracles thank
you
good woke up
you're all right in my book
it's ironic
that a man who wanted us to tap into the
power that we all have within ourselves
is thought of that some sort of divine
being
the point of buddhism as far as i can
see is to teach us that
we are all capable of
much more than
we might believe we are
we just
concentrate on it just put our minds to
it
i used to struggle to make sense of
miracle stories
how oceans could be parted
how it was possible to walk on water
but i think i was missing the point
to believe in miracles is to believe
there is more to life than meets the eye
to accept there could be something that
connects us
unites us
so many souls pass through this world
and as our paths cross
miraculous things can and do happen
people get the breaks they always wanted
people inspire one another
people fall in love
and whether these events are
orchestrated by the hand of god the
power of the mind
or just a 100 million chance
i believe we should believe in miracles
because miracles however you define them
help us to
well they give us hope
they drive us
to create
reality
out of possibility
[Music]
you